foreign
London England where Franklin is joining
us Franklin how can we help
hi uh so I was born and raised outside
of the States you know just to give you
a background and um essentially I don't
have any kind of uh credit history in
the States but I'm moving to the states
in a couple of months for work and I
essentially wanted to find out how best
to build my credit score as quickly as
possible for you know obvious reasons
why you need a great credit score and
the fact that I'm looking to get into
real estate investing
um and so I just wanted to get any tips
that you would have in this regard
that's cool Franklin uh thanks for
calling uh are you familiar with the
Ramsay show are you kind of like a first
time listener how did you find us
so I listen occasionally I I I I I
haven't you know streamed it or called
in or listened live yeah mostly YouTube
videos and on um uh Instagram and and uh
essentially with my pets of it okay
internet okay well you know on here we
teach things a little bit differently uh
we teach to get rid of the credit system
and and to to to get yourself as far
from the need of a credit score and
credit as possible our whole thing here
is paying off your debt so that you
don't have to in building up money so
that your credit score doesn't matter so
I just want to take a moment and kind of
give you that Foundation because if
you're kind of listening here and there
you might not have the whole picture so
I kind of want to give you that picture
so that you don't feel like I'm coming
after you because it might sound like
I'm coming after you a little bit
Franklin but I'm not I just want you to
kind of see where I'm coming from so we
believe that the debt score or the
credit score I should say is nothing
more than a I love debt score it's
basically measuring how you interact
with debt it has nothing to do with how
much money you actually have and I think
that frankly you coming over here to the
United States the whole point is you
want to create this life you want to
make sure the money is good and the
money is Flowing but the credit score
has nothing to do with that so the way
we teach
is that the best way to financial pieces
like this a series of baby steps all
right the first baby step you're getting
a thousand dollars saved the second baby
step is you're paying off all of your
debt except your house the third baby
step after that is you're saving three
to six months of finance and then you go
on to investing baby step four and on up
to baby step seven where you're giving
generously you're buying real estate and
cash you're doing all these wonderful
things so I think that right now we're
not having a meeting of the minds so I
can't tell you what to do and I won't
tell you what to do to improve your
credit score but I will tell you what to
do to improve your relationship with
money and to manage your money to the
optimal degree does that sound all right
yeah yeah it does okay I guess
uh and maybe this is uh uh jumping too
far ahead but I guess my question would
be if you're because I'm again I'm I'm
kind of learning the ropes as to real
estate investing and one thing I've come
to understand is if you want to uh um do
deals a lot of deals um as quickly as
possible it's not very practical to uh
save you know it sure it is sure it is
like yeah it is look at we're trying to
get you to a point of Building Wealth
with as less risk as possible and I know
there's a lot going out there zero down
you know all these different ways to
purchase real estate uh but that's
ultimately that's not the best path and
it's the the most the path that's filled
with the most landmines all right and
we're trying to get you there peacefully
we're trying to get you there safely and
uh here's the thing Franklin you're
going to do what you want to do on this
but you called us
and so we're going to tell you that if
you're purchasing real estate outside of
your personal primary residence that you
need to pay cash for it and save up to
pay cash for it and if you follow the
baby steps you will be able to do that
how old are you
I'm 31 now dude you're young let's work
these baby steps and let's work them in
order do you you're coming over here
when you come over here what's the plan
are you um I mean do you have debt now
no I don't no debt now do you have three
to six months saved up
yes I do you do excellent let's see
professional goal when you get here he
wants to be in real estate uh
so uh so the real estate thing is going
to be my side hustle or I'm uh currently
a lawyer okay um
and I'll be working so you'll be working
as a lawyer yes and what's the income
um
uh somewhere along uh into six figures
apart
it's about it's just below 200. okay all
right so here's what I wanted to say on
this because Jay's absolutely right but
but Franklin if I told you
that I had a strategy for you to build a
house this is a house you're going to
live in in the United States and I told
you that I had a strategy that would
allow us to build the house in 30 days
like really fast
but it was risky would you be in for
that plan
I might no you that's why you're
laughing come on man it's okay to say
you painted me in a corner Ken would you
be up for that strategy Franklin this is
your house
that's what Jade's telling you you watch
all these Instagram videos of people
saying hey you can get in and make all
this money
that's the quick plan but it's also
crazy risky am I right Jade oh ken
you're I mean that's what I'm trying to
help him see what you're saying here
like this is a side hustle why would you
take on something Franklin that is so
risky when you can do it the right way
on the side and as a lawyer You've Got
No Cap to your income
right that's what I'm telling you Jade
has laid it out for you if you work
these steps you're going to be able to
do this Franklin keep going I mean you
got you've done it all you've paid off
your debt you've got that three to six
months man just start saving to pay cash
you've got a good income
the American dream debt Freedom that's
the American dream you're coming over
here I'm letting you know that's the
dream the dream is not having a bunch of
real estate debt